a record surge of cases in hong kong
triggering the city's toughest pandemic
measures yet
today we are in a severe pandemic
situation i hope that the public will
accept that we have to go back to the
most stringent level
from thursday only two people will be
allowed to dine out together more venues
including places of worship will be
ordered to close and for the first time
there will be limitations on private
gatherings at home too
the new round of measures also focus on
the need for vaccine passes in order to
improve low vaccination rates among the
elderly with residents needing to prove
they're immunized against covert 19 to
enter shopping malls and wet markets
fines for those who break the rules will
double to nearly 1 300 u.s dollars
i agree with the measures because the
situation is worsening otherwise how can
we get the virus under control we have
to be patient
i think the government should encourage
people to stay at home instead the
government should open more testing
centers so that people do not have to
gather here
there is no difference between two
people or four people gathering
the government should think about how to
control the spread of the virus
these social distancing measures are
meaningless
a shortage of vegetables is adding to
pandemic grievances in hong kong after
truck drivers who tested positive were
unable to transport them from mainland
china
into the import reliant territory
panicked shoppers swept several local
markets clear of fresh produce
mainland chinese authorities have
offered to help with labor shortages if
hospitals become overwhelmed
for now hong kong appears to be sticking
to the same zero tolerance strategy
adopted by the mainland with lockdowns
and mass testing now commonplace
testing centers like this one are
scattered across the city since cases
started to escalate they've seen a surge
in demand with long queues forming hong
kong's cases might still sound low
compared to other major cities but for
many people here this is uncharted
territory brit clenet al jazeera hong
kong